-My first guest
is a very talented actor
that you know from his work in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
Now he is starring in the highly
anticipated new film "Cherry,"
which hits
select theaters Friday
and will be streaming on Apple
TV Plus starting March 12th.
Here is Tom Holland.
Tom, ah, it's great --
-Hey, Jimmy.
-It's a pleasure to meet you.
Thank you so much.
-Thank you, mate.
Nice to meet you, too.
-I'm a big fan.
I wish you could
be here in person.
But I hear that you've
gotten very comfortable
doing virtual press, if you --
-Yes.
-Maybe a little too --
Maybe a little too comfortable.
I want to show you something.
You posted this photo recently
of your virtual press look.
It made me laugh.
-Let's have a look.
-[ Laughs ]
Oh, yeah.
-That's -- Yeah.
It's only the waist up, man.
I thought that was --
I thought that was rad.
And then Joe Russo, who --
the Russo Brothers,
who has directed you
in "The Avengers"
and your new film, "Cherry,"
decided to copy your look.
Can we take a look at that?
-The thing that kills me
is that Joe's actually
got nicer legs than I do.
-[ Laughs ] He does!
I looked at it, too.
-Look at his legs.
-Does he shave his legs,
you think?
-I don't know what he does.
I don't have to shave my legs,
because I'm like
a prepubescent teenager.
I haven't grown hair
on my legs yet.
Here, look, I'll just give you
a little glance.
-[ Laughing ]
Oh, my God. Oh, my God.
Holy mackerel.
Oh, you're in big trouble
already, man.
Hey, you know
what's interesting?
I was noticing --
You don't wear pants,
but you do wear socks, though.
-Yeah, 'cause it's cold,
and I --
-[ Laughs ]
Of course. Of course it is.
Yeah, I totally get it.
-Because I got to wear
this suit jacket,
and the suit jacket's too hot.
-Yeah.
-But I have my legs out,
'cause it's nice and freeing,
but then my toes get cold,
so I wear my socks.
[ Chuckling ]
Toes get cold. Oh, my God.
I know that you're in Atlanta
shooting the new
Spider-Man movie.
And I know you can't
say much about it.
But there are a lot of rumors
out there.
Some people are saying
that Jamie Foxx might be
coming back as Electro.
No reaction.
There's also a fan theory that
your Spider-Man predecessors,
Tobey Maguire
and Andrew Garfield...
-Right.
-...might be making a cameo
in this movie.
You can't confirm or deny.
-It would be amazing
if they were,
because they haven't
told me that yet.
And I am Spider-Man,
and I've read the script
from the beginning to the end.
So it would be a miracle if they
could have kept that from me.
-Yeah.
-But at the moment,
there is no cameo
from the two boys.
-But they do keep things
from you, though, don't they?
-Yeah, and actually,
it's getting to the point
where it's really frustrating.
-Yeah.
-Because I feel like now
I've progressed.
I'm a trustworthy member
of the Avengers.
And I haven't really ever
spoiled anything.
-Mm.
-Well, there's a few things,
but no big things.
-Wait, you actually have.
You actually have.
-We'll leave it at that.
-But there's one rumor that you
can exclusively confirm tonight.
-Okay, go ahead.
-This will be the first
Spider-Man movie
with two Hollands in it.
-Yes.
-Your little brother Harry
will be in the movie.
Is this correct?
-Yes, this is correct, yeah.
-Who does he play,
and has he shot his part yet?
-Yes, in "Cherry," he has
a small cameo in "Cherry,"
and he plays a character
called the shaky kid,
and he's a drug dealer.
So we kind of had this idea
that in every film I would be in
that Harry would reprise
his role as the shaky kid.
So he is back again
in his own sort of weird
MCU Cinematic Universe cameo
as the ecstasy-dealing
shaky kid.
Yeah.
-Unbelievable.
He's already being typecast.
-I know. It's terrible.
Bless him.
It must be really
difficult for him.
-Is it fun, shooting
with your brother?
Do you pick on each other?
How does it work?
-It's interesting. In the scene,
he gets flipped upside-down.
Spider-Man webs him upside-down,
and then he's
swinging back and forth
while I'm having an argument
with someone,
and he's kind of
swinging through frame.
And I've obviously
done that for years.
Being upside-down
is second nature to me now,
so I know how difficult
it can be.
So at the beginning of the day,
I was, like,
making the takes
extra, extra long
just to see how long it would
take before he blacked out.
[ Both laugh ]
-You're like,
"Can we do that one more time?
Just keep him swinging.
Keep him swinging back there."
-Yeah, I think I forgot my line.
Like [bleep]
what was my line again?
Oh, that's right,
"I'm Spider-Man." And then --
-That was the line.
Sorry. My bad.
-I forgot. I thought
I was Batman for a moment.
-I'm Spider-Man.
That's exactly correct.
-But then towards
the end of the day,
I really did start
to get worried about him.
And I was sort of
saying to the director,
like, "Listen, man,
we got to move on now.
Look at him. He can
hardly speak anymore."
-He's blue, yeah.
-Yeah. Bless him.
It's a funny scene, though,
and it was really fun for me
to get to share
that moment with him.
I'm sure my mum and dad
will be really proud.
-That's cool, bud.
One of the stages where
you're shooting "Spider-Man 3"
is actually the same place
that you originally auditioned
for the role of Spider-Man?
-Yeah.
-And I was just going to --
What was that like,
and in a weird way,
does it bring back flashbacks
of auditioning and going like --
'Cause I remember auditions, and
I never liked them.
-Yeah, it's an interesting
feeling because I walk on-stage,
and I have that moment of panic,
of like, I haven't got my lines.
I'm going to ruin the audition.
I'm not going to get the part.
And then I sort of
look back at my trailer,
which is now way bigger
than it used to be.
And I go, "Ah, I'm okay.
I'm on the third one.
I'm fine. This is all good."
-Uh, yeah, exactly.
It's all good.
I want to talk to you
about your new film, "Cherry."
You're incredible in this.
-Thank you.
-Congrats.
And it's already getting
all sorts of awards buzz.
The movie is about
a lot of things.
It's about war. It's about
addiction. It's about PTSD.
Can you talk about why --
Why was it important for you
to tell this story?
-I think firstly, you know,
I needed to sort of educate
myself on the problem.
The opioid epidemic
wasn't something I knew
particularly very much about.
And I think one of my favorite
things about the film
is my character
doesn't have a name.
And the reason
he doesn't have a name
is because it's not
the story of one person.
We're telling the story
of millions of people
around the world
who are suffering
from this problem
that is addiction and PTSD.
So, for me, I wanted
to make this movie
because I wanted
to help shed light
on a problem that is
on everybody's doorstep.
It's seemingly invisible.
The battle against addiction
is one that always seems
to be fought in the shadows.
So I hope that people
can watch this film
and feel more confident
about opening up, seeking help.
I think seeking help
is something that people
should be heralded for
and congratulated,
saying that, "You've recognized
you've got a problem.
You're seeking help,
and I'm really proud of you."
But unfortunately,
that isn't the case.
So I hope that this film can
really kind of
turn people's perspectives
on what it means to be an addict
and suffering from PTSD.
-In this movie, you --
It follows your character
through lots of
different phases,
including being a heroin addict.
And I read that you lost
30 pounds to do those scenes,
and I heard that
it wasn't shot in order.
So you actually had to --
-No.
-Why? Why not shoot it in order?
-I think that's just
the natural way
of doing an independent film.
You know, the schedule is always
going to be complicated.
-Yeah.
-The thing for me was that
we had a three-month period
before we started shooting
where I could lose the weight.
We then shot
for about eight weeks
where I was doing the dope life
section of the movie
and obviously maintained
that weight loss.
And as we then went into the
chapters of him falling in love,
him joining the Army,
him fighting in Iraq,
I could slowly
put the weight back on.
But during that part
of the film,
the Russos wrote this
new section for dope life,
which is the section
where my wife overdoses,
and I go to the car and have
that awful scene in the car.
And I remember them
pitching me the idea.
And I love the Russos.
I would do anything for them.
But I genuinely felt like
they were trying to kill me.
Like, "I finished that.
I've put that to bed, man."
-You're like, "I just gained
all the weight back.
You're joking, right?"
-Yeah, I was like,
"Is this a joke?
Is someone filming me? Are you
trying to get me to flip out?
What's going on here?"
But, yeah, no, so I had to start
trying to lose weight again.
And then we filmed
those three scenes.
And I'm really proud we did.
I think they really
help the film.
I think they help the narrative
of telling the story
of how tragic the lives
of these people can be.
But it was tough.
It was tough, to say the least.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Tom Holland in "Cherry."
Take a look.
♪♪
-Have you seen bad things?
-Yeah, a little.
-Are people getting killed?
Because I'm seeing on the news
that people are getting killed.
-[ Sobs quietly ]
-Hello?
-Yeah, baby, I'm here.
-You're going to make it
through this, okay?
I know that you're going
to make it through this.
♪♪
-Could you just
talk about you for a second?
What's going on with you?
-Tom Holland, everybody.
When we come back,
Tom and I are going head-to-head
in a brand-new game.
It's gonna be fun.
Stick around.